this is a 3d printer and it's ink is
alive thanks to some helpful bacteria
that can do things like degrade
pollutants so the researchers called the
new ink flink
it's a functional living ink with flank
researchers can make functional material
in any shape they could even put one
kind of helpful bacteria here and a
different kind there and the printed
material is strong enough to keep
printed shapes even complex ones flank
also has potential uses in medicine when
it's loaded with bacteria that make
cellulose with flank researchers can
make cellulose scaffolds that are useful
as tissue envelopes for organ
transplants and that may help protect
patients against organ rejection the
researchers also made a scaffold on the
uneven and varied surface of a doll's
face
that means the cellulose film could be
used for skin grafts as well without
risking the formation of wrinkles or
creating pockets of material that could
trap contaminants and that is something
to write home about
[Music]